[Music]
annoying ads got you down missing videos
due to YouTube's constantly changing
notification settings seeing videos you
didn't sign up for when you subscribed
no there's gotta be a better way hi I'm
Ayanna weight of channel Lawson's orbit
report and formerly awesome comics yeah
those shows you don't watch and I'm here
today in an approachable primary colored
polo and khakis to bring you channel
awesome the latest news with modern
binge watching culture and the rise of
originally produced content on streaming
services such as Amazon Hulu and Netflix
other companies like CBS Disney and even
DC are announcing streaming services of
their own not to be left in the dust
channel awesome has an announcement
introducing the awesome stream you'll be
seeing awesome
every time you stream before now we
brought you free content daily covering
an array of topics rest assured we'll
still bring you the same frequency and
quality content but now the low low
price of 895 a month watching The Critic
has never been so streamlined search for
your favorite personalities and even
enjoy exclusive content not available
elsewhere
will even give you suggestions on what
to watch next based on your specific
interests
[Music]
but wait we haven't even gotten to our
best feature yet we know you're only
here to watch dog so we've created an
option on every show to cover those
unfortunately non dog faces simply
switch to doug mode in the special
features tab and those pesky people are
gone and replaced with Doug hey everyone
welcome to channel awesomes Orbitz
report your source for everything
happening around the world and pop
culture and entertainment news good
I'm Heather Roos and I'm Ayanna Wade
what's up everybody I'm Walter bond 11c
ak and I'm here to go over the top 11
worst Tim Curry performances it's no
come on Tim Curry come on
[Music]
you always shown these making of videos
and something I want you get shot
yourself get shot yourself man yeah do
it hey oh hey guys welcome to another
episode of awesome builts today I'm
gonna show you how to make your own
personal Jesus let's go hi guys my
name's Tamra chambers and this is
Tamra's never seen I'm gonna start off
with this high-pitched Shepherd thing
and then go to Kyle is lower
you know subscribe now for just 895 a
month Wow only nine dollars its 895 it's
very clear about that it says it right
on the screen and coming soon comment
directly to show I can see your boobs I
can't see your boobs I bet you saw that
movie you're lying about not seeing it
you